just
days before the 20th anniversary of the
9 11 attacks pre-trial hearings for the
accused architect of the massive terror
plot are set to begin
lucas thomason is at guantanamo bay cuba
with details
20 years after the 9 11 attacks there
has never been a trial for those accused
of planning it after proceedings pause
for more than a year due the coronavirus
pandemic pre-trial hearings set to
resume wednesday 15 years ago more than
a dozen high-value detainees arrived at
gitmo from cia black sites around the
world including accused 911 mastermind
khalid sheikh mohammed also known by his
initials ksm
then president bush announced their
arrival it is invaluable to america and
to our allies we're not for this program
our intelligence community believes that
al qaeda and its allies would have
succeeded in launching another attack
against the american homeland the
attorney for ksm's nephew another gitmo
detainee accused of wiring 125 thousand
dollars to the 911 hijackers from the
united arab emirates tells fox news his
client was tortured if 15 years of
indefinite detention of guantanamo have
taught us anything
it's that justice for america cannot
coexist with the abandonment of american
values khalid sheikh mohammed charged
with killing nearly 3 000 people on 9
11. prosecutors say he boasted about
planning the attacks
ksm will be in court at gitmo wednesday
along with four other high-value
prisoners ksm is one of 39 prisoners
remaining here at gitmo down from a high
of 680 during the bush administration
today it costs 13 million dollars a year
to house each prisoner compared to 70
000 a year for a convicted terrorist the
super max prison in colorado
while the bite administration is under
pressure to close gitmo foxes learn
there's a multi-million dollar expansion
to build new classified workspaces
congressman mike waltz says it's worth
it we still need a capacity
to detain these folks
and detain these individuals and not put
them in the united states
there's still no trial set for khalid
sheikh mohammed or any other terrorists
here at gitmo some officials question if
one will ever take place and even if it
does the appeals process likely to last
another 10 to 20 years meaning these men
will most likely die in cuba and not be
executed mike lucas thomason live in
gitmo lucas thanks a lot hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else